we're doing this and it's about 8 30 in
the morning and we get some good intel
and you know we get with karzai and we
get a good decision from him and we
start
um
we start our operations up well we had a
very very good process for
clearing our fires we had a great sts
guy on the ground
and we have absolutely no errors and we
we needed to build up our four structure
going into af going into kandahar
so
we took this point
we took this point in time
to bring in some additional uh
augmentees right
and
it was about 24 hours before this had
happened so what we did was
we
um
we did a good transition with everybody
we had attacked p come in and he did
good transition with the sts and learned
all the sops and everything like that
and
our sds guy and the attack p had uh
changed over
so just so everyone knows these these
are the guys that
call for fire from the air that's what
we're talking about
the tacp and the sts these are
individuals that are trained that's what
they do
it's i mean obviously it's a really hard
job
one mistake can be deadly and that's
what they're focused on and it's great
to have those guys because that's what
they do for a living right and so you
had a transition taking place where
you're going from one guy that had been
with you now your your force is growing
you got some extra guys that are going
to be able to help out
but they're just showing up so
they're not quite up to up to speed yet
that's correct that's correct and um
and so
they did their transition
we had got a mail in for the first time
so guys were you know
guys that weren't directly involved in
doing anything were opening up their
mail and you know
i had done a walk around our
our defensive area which was an old
soviet uh
mortar pit right up in the high ground
and i'd walked around and i had gone
down the hill
just got to the bottom of the hill
and this big explosion right out of
nowhere
and um
i don't know how much time it passed to
be honest with you but i picked myself
up off the ground i
had pieces of
body parts stuff all over me blood all
over me i'm doing a quick assessment of
myself
i got a real bad injury with my leg
and um
you know
dazed looking around and it is utter
mayhem
we got afghans down we got americans
down we got
rounds cooking off we got rpgs cooking
off it's going all over the place
um
i start walking around i start grabbing
our guys
we go down to where karzai was and we
made sure he was okay and he was with
his cia guys and they had secured him
and the guys that were with him securing
him
i asked them if they would go out and
recon a safe place to bring in
helicopters because i knew we were going
to have to cast a vac here
and out 200 meters we had casualties
right
it was it was a mess
all 20 of the u.s guys on the ground
were injured some way or another some
more than others
and
we had
i designated a casualty control point
and i got with my comms guys and we had
to find some
uh we had to
kind of like
take
com's equipment from
you know cannibalize it from other stuff
to make to re-establish communications
with higher headquarters
i found colonel fox and he was
he was dazed and confused
just to the point where he was just not
coherent about what was going on so made
sure that he was
taken care of
um and
went up on the hill and we started
pulling bodies off right with all these
rounds cooking off and everything like
getting getting guys off the top of the
hill getting them down
and we knew we had
to get
complete accountability of everybody
and
we did that and i was missing one right
went back up on the hill
to where his position was and
that was ground zero of the impact of
the two thousand pound bomb from a
b-52 up 35 000 feet
and
i searched everywhere
i found his hat
and i took his hat and i started picking
up
bits and pieces and i put it inside the
hat and i put the hat inside a bag and i
parked it
and that's how he was identified
but there was nothing to send home
absolutely nothing to send him
and another one of our
guys that was killed was completely torn
in half
i found him under a vehicle
his
chest was still heaving
his legs were over here his chest his
body was separated from it
and i start doing cpr on him
and someone finally grabs me on the
shoulder and goes sir
no
it's not gonna work he's torn in half
so anyways we get him in in a body bag
and we
get him off there and then we had one
guy that was not gonna make it
but was
still alive and we kept them alive and
we got them evact
when the
when we had coordinated the evac
we got
a b team
special forces company and an oda to
come in to backfill
that came in from higher headquarters we
got all the guys out uh and
then we started doing the um
the after action and regrouping because
we still had this was 5 december
we still had to go
and take kandahar
so me
my assistant s3
the battalion commander and a common guy
despite our injuries we stayed on the
ground
in order to be able to coordinate the
push to canar
so we did that we regrouped we got as
many afghans out as we possibly could
that were injured
that wasn't something that
higher wanted to do but we talked him
into doing it because it was the right
thing to do so we got our afghan
partners evac out
we helped with the casualties for them
as well in the village and everybody
came out and and helped from the
different
areas around the village
um and
um
we just said screw it we're gonna
we're gonna hit that um
we're gonna hit that bridge we're gonna
hit that uh pass and
we're gonna knock him out of there and
we went through
nobody was there
right
this was 8 december and we went right
into kandahar and we took kandahar and
the after action on that though
and i blame myself to this day
the transition between the sts and
attack p was really good
but the tacp
had to change batteries
and and those old soft lamps that we
used to target designate
when you do that the grid resets to your
position
so before you send anything or confirm
anything with the
aircraft you've got to make sure that
that you have your grid system squared
away
and that was the mistake that was made
and
as i go over this in my mind over and
over and over again even to this day i
think to myself
i should have been there
to make sure that
that i should have gotten an in-person
briefing from the tacp that
he knew all those procedures i should
have got that and i didn't get that and
because i didn't get it
because of we're in combat and because
of all the things that you talked about
earlier
um
you know a mistake was made and
i
i was in charge of those operations on
behalf of colonel fox that was my job
and i didn't do my job in my opinion to
the best of my ability and we had that
event occur
and
you know
well i learned a big lesson uh and i'm
sure a lot of people learned a big
lesson but at the end of the day
um
it um you know there's a
and i think you talk about it and you
know in your in your book there extreme
ownership the fog of war right
and klaus wits and his explanation of
the fog of war and i mean it's all there
right and
you do what you can do
in some cases you can only do so much
there's a lot of things going on
but in retrospect it becomes clearer
and as you say you got to take extreme
ownership
right
not only on those things that go well
but most importantly on those things
that don't go well
at what point did you realize it was a
friendly bomb
well
it wasn't until
i was talking to the tacp
who was seriously injured
and he was apologizing
and he said i sir i made a mistake i
don't think
that i i cleared that grid
like i was supposed to do
and i said hey listen
mistakes happen
these things happen
please
you need you need to focus on keeping
yourself i mean he was seriously in you
need to focus on keep yourself alive so
you can get home to your family
these things happen